if you had not two but
three eyes
where would you like your third eye to
be
sure the back of your head would be the
obvious choice but
what if you placed it somewhere
unexpected
how would your third eye see the world
in what ways could it make your life
better
and
why could it turn into a nightmare
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you had three eyes
some members of the animal kingdom have
more eyes than us
certain spiders have up to eight eyes
and that gives them greater motion
detection and depth perception
there's also a third eye located on top
of the head of some amphibians sharks
and lizards
it's called the parietal eye
you've most likely never seen it since
it's covered by a thin layer of skin
it can be easier to spot on younger
lizards if you look closely
this third eye has its own lens and
retina
it could also act like a compass
pretty wild right
so if some animals proudly rock their
third eye
why should we be settling for two
let me tell you we almost had a chance
to evolve with three eyes
our pineal gland the one responsible for
hormone regulation is a sort of an
atrophied light sensor
had our evolution been slightly
different
there'd be an extra 8 billion eyeballs
on the planet
yeah this could have been too much for
our foreheads to handle
but this eye-catching addition could
have given you greater depth perception
maybe even increased night vision if
your forehead eye contained more rods
these rods help you see in the dark and
the more of them you have the better
your ability to see in low light
environments
and if your third eye had more cones you
would see color differently
just one extra cone cell could help you
see 99 million more colors than you
normally do
i think that would be cool don't you
yeah okay i'll stop unfortunately
chances are your third eye wouldn't be
nearly as advanced
an eye is cognitively taxing for your
brain
adding one to your body might feed you a
lot of information but you'd have
limited mental resources to process it
most likely your third eye would only be
good for detecting light and movement
but not much else
which is about as much as the parietal
eye can do in other species
now why does that third eye have to be
at the front
couldn't you at least get it in the back
of your head
wouldn't we have been safer from all the
predators hunting us back in prehistoric
times
well you might think so but millions and
millions of years of evolution disagree
yeah the extra eye would be limited to
helping distinguish the motion of
potential threats
this might be why even eight eyed
spiders have all of their peepers facing
forward
primates like us are extremely social
we rely on our tribes rather than our
super organs to protect us from
predators
and we're still equipped with great
hearing that gives us advance notice if
trouble is lurking nearby
was that
was that
also imagine how limited your hair style
options would be with a third eye on the
back of your head
not to mention that always seeing what's
behind you would probably distract you
from focusing on what's in front of you
but what if your third eye wasn't on
your head at all
what if it evolved somewhere around your
belly button area
you know to give you the low angle view
of the world
imagine driving a car while staring at
the new pair of shoes you just picked up
or putting on a wool sweater yeah
there's something in my eye
everything about your world would change
in order to accommodate this optic
edition
but with this third eye being so much
less advanced than our other two
what's the point in having it at all
maybe evolution has something else in
store for us as our bodies continue
evolving
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
[Music]
you